VOICE
From lazy Adam Sandler, comes yet
another lazy plotless farted-out
comedy, that America will
inexplicably pay to see...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Grown Ups.
Join an all-star cast of comedic
actors...and Rob Shneider, as they
dish out more of the mindless crap
audiences love:
VOICE (CONT'D)
Pee jokes.
Poop jokes.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Fart jokes.
More pee jokes.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And...more fart jokes.
Prepare to give up your own hard
earned money to pay for these rich
actors to go on vacation with their
families.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Seriously. This movie cost 80
million dollars, and they shot it
at a lake!
VOICE (CONT'D)
It's lowest common denominator
comedy at it's laziest,
substituting plot, wit, and
character with guys getting hit in
the faces...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Guys getting hit in the foot...
Guys getting hit in the dick...
VOICE (CONT'D)
And even more fart jokes.
Journey along with these celebrity
man-babies, as they try to become
grown ups!
VOICE (CONT'D)
Lenny's got Adam Sandler problems:
he's too rich and his wife is too
hot.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Kurt is African American, but he
can't play basketball.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Higgs will have sex with anything,
just like David Spade
VOICE (CONT'D)
Robb has two hot daughters, that
his friends creepily want to bang.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And fat Kevin James is fat.
Did we mention he's totally fat?
VOICE (CONT'D)
Hahaha! (Fart noise)
So get ready for another lazy Adam
Sandler movie full of the things
you've come to expect:
VOICE (CONT'D)
Product placement
Adam Sandler's friends
VOICE (CONT'D)
And jokes so devoid of humor,
creativity, or effort you won't
know when to laugh...but don't
worry, they will!
VOICE (CONT'D)
Alright we got it.
OK, that's enough.
VOICE (CONT'D)
It's really not funny, guys.
Still not funny.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Jeez, it's really not funny.
Starring...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Not Chris Farley
Also Not Chris Farley
VOICE (CONT'D)
Every Movie Hates Chris
Las Bewbs
VOICE (CONT'D)
Adam Sandler's Friend
Whoever that cross-eyed dude is.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And a carrot.
Grown Ups
VOICE (CONT'D)
You know, if you see Grown Ups 2
you're only encouraging him. NOOOOO!